how'd you get that name man [ __ ]
honestly we put the mic in front of you
and and the applesauce or juice up it's
[ __ ] that's amen I respect it but I
like that bro but um it's better than
lean right
you can't get addicted to Honest Kids
organic super fruit punch and if you did
you wouldn't have withdrawals if you
stopped drinking it I'd be having Honest
Kids withdrawals I'm not gonna lie
Honest Kids withdrawals yeah that's what
I mean it's good I'm sure it's good
right yes I yeah so your name how do we
get to it uh [ __ ] it's a long story if
I'm summing it up like can we get the
mic uh closer yeah there we go there we
go there we go so like long story short
I was in school I was going through some
[ __ ] okay dipping dad and [ __ ] I felt
like that was bad for me what were you
doing
just so like that [ __ ] had me feeling
crazy I felt like if I kept doing that I
would destroy myself then before that I
spent a bunch of time by myself so I
just called myself lonely because I
really was by myself I was homeschooled
spent a lot of time in the crib [ __ ] wow
yeah so quite a literal name very little
yeah